let's get to the
standard deviation the standard deviation indicates the range of
a variable around the mean
value it will have the standard deviation the
average distance of all
measured values ​​of a variable from the mean value of
the distribution therefore the
standard deviation indicates how much
all values ​​scatter on average
let's take a look at it  using this
example where we look at the height of people
first of all the mean
value has to be calculated now of course every
person has a deviation from the mean let’s
say this person deviates
from the mean value by 30 centimeters this
person by eight centimeters
this person by 12 cm and  this person
by six centimeters and so on and
so forth so every person has a certain
deviation from the mean
now it might be interesting for him to
know how big the deviation is for all people
so we want to
know how much the whole person
deviates from the mean on average
this gives us the standard deviation for
the calculation of the standard deviation
there are two slightly different
equations
on the one hand you can use
the entire
population to calculate the standard deviation on the other hand
this can also be calculated if only
a random sample is
available all values ​​of
the population are available you use  However
, we only
use this formula to calculate the standard billing. This formula is used for a random sample. The
main difference here is that
a - stands up and here we only have
the result.
Otherwise, both formulas
are completely identical  abbreviated if we calculate the
standard deviation based on a
random sample, this is written
with lower case it is of course also
interesting to know what the
difference is between the variance and the
standard deviation the difference
between  n the care parameters
variance and standard deviation is
that the standard deviation measures the
average distance from the
mean and the variance measures the
quartered average distance
from the mean the
other way around the variance is the
squares of the standard deviation and the
standard deviation is the root of the
variant let's just have a look here
the two forms on
on the one hand we have the
variance on the other hand will have
the standard deviation then
we can see that both forms are completely
identical and except that with the
standard deviation the root is
taken again the life at the alliance is
not done when  When
reporting results, the standard deviation is usually always
used because the
standard deviation has the same
units as the original variable.
If we go back to the example
we measured height,
let's say we have height in
centi  meters and it turned
out that the mean value is 180
centimeters now we
can calculate the standard deviation and it
could come out that the
standard deviation is 15 centimeters now
we know that the people on
average deviate by 15 centimeters from the mean
value we would calculate the result with the variance  you would have to
pull the root of the report yourself so that you
can better classify the result
if you haven’t quite googled data tab yet just google
for the type of offender on
datatec you will find super tutorials and
evaluate your data directly online in no time at all
if you want to be informed
as soon as a new  video of me
coming out just subscribe to this
channel and click the bell thanks and see you
next time